The modern workplace is increasingly
extending beyond the four walls of your
office. We're working in airplanes, coffee
shops, or in the comfort of our own homes
But with the flexibility can come
frustration of not having your full
office set up. With just one headset you
can surround yourself with as many
virtual monitors as you please. Mount
Rogers provides portable infinite screen
space wherever you go. You have the full
power of the windows that you know and
love, with reconfigurable private
monitors. Say you get an Excel
spreadsheet attached in an email that's
way too big for your screen.
With one click, you can make the screen
bigger and see everything at once.
Because the headset renders images in
stereo, the user can pull objects from a
2d virtual monitor into a 3d space,
reposition them, and return them to their
document. Our current research prototypes
allow for hours of use in real-world
conditions, and we are excited by what
the future holds.
Headset technology is getting smaller
and lighter and the resolution is only
getting better. No more worrying about
having enough monitor real estate at
your desk, or on the go. With Mount Rogers
take the workspace you want
wherever you want